he's got a fixation with some of these
Legacy Outlets particularly the New York
Times because he considers that his
hometown paper still
um I would much rather him put his
efforts in supporting
shows like yours shows like what will be
mine
um why not I I don't because here's the
thing that
so many times people say well you're
just talking to yourself that's not true
if Trump talks to Dave Rubin the New
York Times will write about it NBC will
cover it uh it's just a fact right and
and they will cover this so why not
support the people who are trying to
build up this ecosystem of folks on the
right and allow them to be successful so
did you ever give him that kind of
advice when
um I tried once and um I I I I I I was
very clear about a particular right
after the election he was going down to
the New York Times Movie Theater award I
was not in favor of that
he let me know in various dark terms uh
that he really didn't care what I
thought
is it odd to you that these guys can't
course correct I always say it's like
the media doesn't have to be great I
would just prefer they not be completely
they seem unable like the Titanic they
see that they see the iceberg I often
wondered that myself I'd say why don't
like after the 2016 election I was in
New York City
um obviously that's where Trump
headquarters was senior Executives from
NBC called and said can we have coffee
can we talk so we we had with this sit
down and they said we're gonna we
realized we missed a lot of this so
we're gonna set up these pop-up bureaus
around America and I'm like so let me
get this straight you're gonna go to
like Cedar Rapids for like a week and
think that like your New York dude is
going to suddenly get in touch with all
of these farmers and people who depend
on the land and but their their idea was
like it was like a field trip yeah I
mean and there is a complete
utter misunderstanding of and I I think
there was no bigger
to me realization
then when Trump did this town hall and
CNN the other night all of these folks
on the left and in the media
broke down the next day and apologized
Anderson Cooper went off on this rant
but here's the thing that I said you
never watched CNN right but but the
thing that I thought was fascinating
Walter Shapiro put out an op-ed that
said we should never do live audiences
again and you're like because why yeah
because you didn't control it remember
that audience was picked hand-picked by
CNN but let me go back to Anderson
Cooper he gets on and does this
monologue about how you know I'm sorry
if you were offended now regardless of
whether you like Trump or not at the end
of the day he is currently the the
leading candidate for the Republican
nomination and according to ABC
Washington Post he leads Biden by seven
okay so that means let's call it a
majority of Voters in both the primary
and in the general are supportive of
trump who are you apologizing to if
you're supposed to be a down the middle
media organization in theory you should
be catering to 50 50. that's what CNN
says that they do so why are you
apologizing because what 46 were
offended or upset because they live in a
bubble and I'm convinced that that gets
to the nut of your question they don't
talk to anyone or see anyone that thinks
differently from them so they finish
their afternoon whatever they do after
CNN and then fly by helicopter to The
Hamptons hang around a bunch of people
who think the same way they do fly back
go to some fundraiser or charity event
where everyone talks about the same
things that they do I just don't think
that there's an understanding that
there's another part of the country
other than the one that they live in and
so it's an ignorance that I think is
driving this you think it might have
been a risk to call everybody a big and
a racist for 10 years because then
eventually you really you can't talk to
anybody else in the end right you end up
in that exact situation so I I think for
a lot of these folks
when you look at the parties and
political Playbook has been warning
digestive you know who was spotted at
what it's always the same people at the
same events talking to each other on the
left they never invite anybody on the
right they just and so the the media
folks are talking to a bunch of elected
Democrats and political operatives on
the left so they all hear the same thing
and they think somehow that's just the
prevailing narrative I think that's the
biggest problem right now is that there
is no cross-pollination I say to people
all the time believe me I get yelled at
by democrats uh by folks in the left by
Trump haters so I I see it I hear it I'm
very well aware that a lot of people
don't like the Republican Party
conservative policies Donald Trump but I
think for folks on the left they don't
see the other side they don't think that
there is anybody that supports
conservative policies that wants a
secure border that stands up for Life
those things to them are just that they
don't get it they're they're going I
don't know who who are these people that
you speak of right well a guy like me is
to out there for them I mean I've never
been on CNN ever I've put out two
best-selling books we tried to get on
CNN
but in in you know you know you're a
very reasonable person like you've been
on the left in a way that's a bigger
risk for them right that's the problem
it's a threat yeah right so you talk
about your evolution in your book uh
you've talked about the people that
you've been around the the Outreach I
know in on your show you talk a lot
about the the efforts that you've made
to reach out to Democrats to appear
to to them they don't want you there
they don't want to hear another thing
it's funny you think about like some of
these Sunday shows they have round
tables
they've never had ABC CBS one person
that supports Donald Trump
now I think to myself you may not like
him but go back to the statistics he is
the leading candidate and he is
currently either tied maybe a point or
two behind or in front of Donald I mean
of Joe Biden but it's going to be a
close race if he's the nominee and yet
they don't want a single person on their
show to give people perspective as to
what he's doing or why why because you
don't want people to know let me ask you
about the media strategy of your your
former boss Trump so one of my
frustrations with him has been that he
is feeding the very machine that you're
talking about by going on CNN he's
telling you they're the failing New York
Times and failing CNN and you have no
ratings but at the same time he's
empowering that very machine and to me
that's a that's a real problem in terms
of selective pressures I would rather
the machine just die and let's let's go
to the new ground right let's go to the
promised land what do you think about
that I I'm with you on that I I've never
been a big fan
of him
supporting the people who are coming
after him he's doing interviews with her
and he's got a fixation with some of
these Legacy Outlets particularly the
New York Times because he considers that
his hometown paper still
um I would much rather him put his
efforts in supporting
shows like yours shows like what will be
mine
um why not I I don't because here's the
thing that
so many times people say well you're
just talking to yourself that's not true
if Trump talks to Dave Rubin the New
York Times will write about it NBC will
cover it uh it's just a fact right and
and they will cover this so why not
support the people who are trying to
build up this ecosystem of folks on the
right and allow them to be successful so
did you ever give him that kind of
advice when
um I tried once and um I I I I I I was
very clear about a particular right
after the election he was going down to
the New York Times the editorial board I
was not in favor of that
he let me know in very Stark terms uh
that he really didn't care what I
thought well so your feeling was oh
they're gonna lie about you no matter
what why are you I also thought why are
we rewarding them this close to after
the election they didn't help us they
hated us and they're not going to change
their position because you go to them in
fact I I thought optically it looked bad
we're you are the president-elect they
come to you you don't go to them number
one number two why of all the
organizations are they at the top of the
list they should be at the bottom of the
list you want to do them have a bunch of
conservative folks media and have some
people that were treated you fairly
um and then get to them but at the why
are we leading with them
um but you know his view was I can
handle anyone he can and that's it's not
I always viewed it as that's not he he
handled himself I think brilliantly at
the CNN Town Hall it's not a question of
can you handle it but he gave them 3.1
million viewers that night the highest
they beat every other station
and so well I guess he understands that
if he does that for them they'll keep
talking about him right and then he'll
go back to them so that's what I'm
saying it becomes this odd
self-fulfilling prophecy that they'll
both continue right and I think that
that's sort of a problem at this point I
agree and part of the reason that
I I've never supported him doing that
and I still don't is because of that
exact reason I think that the more that
we give them
Credence to go after him he talks to him
that no one treats him fairly I mean he
has sat down for books interviews
um documentaries you name it and it
always comes out looking poorly on him
no matter what and so why let that
happen because if he goes and talks to
somebody else they'll still cover it so
you'll get your your your thing you're
not going to win them over it's just not
going to happen and I think that's what
you know I think somehow he believes if
he keeps chipping away he has this
businessman mentality and I get it which
is I'm gonna get a deal with you you're
gonna like me and I think people
probably do come away liking him saying
wow he's not what I thought they're not
going to go back to their editor and say
I tell you what it went really well I'd
like to write something nice about the
guy that's not going to happen if you're
looking for more uncensored opinions
from today's thought leaders check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a wide variety
of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell